Maybe he did a bad,
bad thing. Yeah.
All I know,
you could be the bad guy.
And I could be
the, the other bad guy.
I'm really starting
to not like you.
Oh, come on.
Not like me?
You don't even know me.
We could have
a lot in common.
Know what, Booth,
maybe I don't know you,
but been building a profile
on you ever since you stole
William Strang's
Lady with the Red Hat
from the tape back in 2014.
You can't prove that was me.
I got that on Etsy.
Given your escape history,
what're you six for six now?
Yep. One more and I get
a Shawshank jacket.
Keep making your jokes,
I'm about to send you
to the worst place
in the world.
Your Instagram account?
Are you a top or a bottom?
It doesn't matter,
prison's gonna decide
for us.
I do not know
where the third egg is,
I swear to God.
I know
where the third egg is.
I swear to God.
It's not
that I don't care about you,
it's that I don't care
about anyone.
These people are horrible,
but I like money, so...
These guys,
if they find out,
they find out
you're a C-O-P.
This is a room
full of convicted murderers
and toilet vodka
enthusiasts.
We gotta make sure that
they know you're not a cop.
Don't... Listen to me!
Damn...
Guys!
Not a cop.
This man is not a cop.
All right? Get that through
your thick skulls right now.
He's a profiler
with the FBI,
which does under the
umbrella of law enforcement,
but not a cop.
Similar,
but not the same thing.
It's a complicated
backstory, all right?
This is our good friend
Special Agent John Hartley.
Let's give him a warm
welcome to the prison, guys.
Say what you will
about rust in prisons,
but soap, it's incredible.
-Smell it.
-Don't gotta smell it.
Why are you wearing
the hairnet?
You're bald.
Can you fly a helicopter?
Does the back of your head
look like a huge penis?
The answer is yes.
You were gonna leave me?
You said, "Save yourself."
I said, "Go."
I didn't mean without me.
You said, "Go,
save yourself."
But I was gonna carry you
with me in my heart
like an eternal flame,
you stupid complainer.
This is my best friend.
We're not friends.
We're best friends.
Bulls have terrible eyesight
but they can sense motion.
You're thinking of
Jurassic Park.
No!
I saw a nature documentary
starring David Attenborough.
You're thinking
of Richard Attenborough
from Jurassic Park!
Right, yes or no?
Was Jeff Goldblum in it?
Ooh, my God!
It was Jurassic Park.
That's Jeff Goldblum.
Build a bunker,
bring in the loot,
seal the shaft
and Bob's your uncle.
-He was your daddy.
-That's not how it goes.
-Two birds, one stone.
-Egg.
-What?
-Two birds, one egg.
It's kind of a lay up,
even Post Malone get's it.
So, if we don't
get his thumb print,
-we can't get the egg?
-Oh, my God.
You can learn.
Not used to working
with a partner.
We're not partners.
A marriage of convenience.
I want a divorce
and I'm keeping the kids.
-We're not friends.
-We're work wives.
-We're not work wives.
-Sister wives.
-Not any kind of wives!
-Shut up, both of you!
You look mean.
I hate you.
I don't need your apologies,
I need a wash room!
Take him.
Right this way, sir.
Let's get you hosed down.
You're like
a well-dressed wall.
I didn't see
the handcuffs coming.
I have
such a confusing erection.
You saved me!
You love me.
You wanna talk about
what just happened?
-What're you talking about?
-Our moment.
-Just had a moment.
-We didn't have a moment.
I know, we had a moment.
The egg.
That gun is soaking wet,
there's no way in hell--
I'm not a navy seal.
Know what I think
is funny, Booth?
Vin Diesel's audition tape
for Cats exists?
As an added bonus,
my friend here,
at no extra charge,
is gonna give you
a lifetime supply of prison.
Serious question.
You guys have any sunblock?
I have no base.
This is a spray tan.
A fancy yacht,
you think they could stock
some decent cheeses.
That's not cheese.
That's uncooked pork.
I've heard tapeworms
can be quite slimming.
We won. Together.
Friendship. Teamwork.
It's called
the moral of the story.
I came aboard yesterday.
You weren't
the only one crying
at the end
of your love making.
What are we stealing?
This.